craft beer scene in southern nevada
continues to overflow with opportunity
next week north fifth brewing will open
as the first craft brewery in north las
vegas kate houston spoke to the owner
about how their family and local roots
inspired the business
we love craft beer and to be able to
make it our own and when we were able to
pour our first beer out of our tap
handle it was just so rewarding after
three years amanda pion and her brother
are preparing to open their brewery
inside their parents former construction
business the beers are named for their
family and landmarks of north las vegas
we loved to incorporate that important
part of our family history because being
third generation business owners here in
north las vegas we wanted to include
that a little bit of our family heritage
pion says shipping and supply issues
from the pandemic extended their budget
and timeline but they were able to work
around it even the price of you know the
stuff for construction everything went
up plumbing went up electrical went up
and it's just due to the shortage of
everything despite some challenges north
fifth brewing is now one of five
businesses opening in the city in two
months extremely important because these
are jobs that pay a decent salary so
it's a livable wage so that you will be
able to raise your family and feed your
family and so that's extremely important
councilwoman pamela goines-brown says
the city is now working to open even
more firsts bringing quality restaurants
sit down restaurants fast food
restaurants so there are a lot of firsts
in that area because there are not many
places like that in north las vegas and
craig road is just evolving into just
that kate houston live local now
the brewery scene in las vegas and north
las vegas and henderson it's good stuff
yeah i love that craft beer good stuff
now